what is socialism
that's another loaded term
socialism particularly in america is a
very loaded term and what americans call
socialist is um a large amount of
provision of services by the state which
is commonplace in europe it's still
moderately commonplace in my own home
country of australia
and
and that americans are we'll call you
know public education socialist it's a
total parody of the word
uh
strictly speaking what socialism meant
is the public ownership of the means of
production no private ownership for the
means of production what is the means of
production machine factories factories
so
all the goods that are produced in
factories no the means
of producing the goods owned by a
centralized entity yeah
centrally planned this is what it was
actually was done under god's plan under
the soviets uh and even with a
collective collective farms as well you
know no longer owns your land the state
owns your own the land you worked on the
land and this was supposed to be a
utopia
right now turn out to be one and we'll
talk about maybe your ideas of why it
didn't turn out to be one uh so the the
fascists did the same so it's just
fascism also
fascism
so called national socialism it's also a
kind of social so yeah but there was no
it wasn't a public owner there was
public direction so the state would tell
factories what to do with a still
private profit and a large part of why
the nazis succeeded was the extent to
which they managed to co-opt major
manufacturers in germany
so
it's you know it's direction versus
ownership it's a dictatorial i mean
that's a very particular implementation
yeah so you have to you have to consider
the full details of the implementation
but it's basically
dictator guided yeah
if you want to if you want to take this
if you want to take a a proper vision
then you have to say it's the ownership
of the means of production by the state
yeah okay versus the ownership by
private that rules out the nazi period
do you use the word that again they're
bastardizing as much as americans do in
the opposite direction
well what does ownership exactly mean
well it's
it it became incredibly complicated and
this is um the and this is actually the
best work on this is done by a recently
deceased hungarian economist called
janos cornei
and corney tried to explain why
socialism failed
okay because why did socialism fail in
your view in his view in giannis's view
and your review i think janus is 100
correct and it's it's a brilliant piece
of work so i'm going to be really
paraphrasing his view and he imagined a
ideal socialist society and there wasn't
a stalin there weren't perjures and you
lived up to all the ideals that marx had
for socialism so he said in in but you
do it in a in a context of a economy
which is incredibly primitive russia
okay because if you look at marx's own
vision of the revolution it was going to
happen in england
okay the advanced economies would be
first to go through the revolution the
socialist the the primitive economies
would have to go through a capitalist
transition and this is the difference
between the mensheviks and the
bolsheviks so the mensheviks and heiman
minsky came out of the menshevik family
the mensheviks believed you had to go
through a capitalist phase russia had to
go through a capitalist period before it
become socialist the bolsheviks believed
they could get there in one go
okay
bypass the capitalist phase do the
development under uh
socialism rather than under capitalism
and this is what jana janus was actually
analyzing you start from a primitive
you know
feudal economy
very little industrialization and you
want to
jump to a
in advanced industrial society
from that foundation
so he said what you
have then for is a whole range of
industries all of which need as much
resources as you can get for them okay
so you want to develop agriculture
mining in industry every little division
of it they all have legitimate demands
on the resources of the country and the
state
that means that all your resources are
fully employed and are probably over
employed
so you have a resource constraint
in that society
the easiest way to cope with a resource
constraint is to produce last year's
commodity
not to innovate not to make change so
what they will give you is as you start
to
add you know you invest so you now have
a beginnings of a steel industry
beginnings of a car industry and so on
you start investing but you continue
producing the same product you made last
year
and i have a perfect personal example of
that which i'll throw in now if you like
any pretty heavy conversation i know my
first major girlfriend uh had a
brother
who
wanted to get a motorbike but he
couldn't afford a
honda or a kawasaki at the time they
cost about three thousand dollars for a
650cc japanese motorbike he found he
could buy a
cossack for six hundred and fifty
dollars one dollar per cc
so i was there when i got breastfeeding
this this is in her this is in
suburban sylvania waters you know in
sydney so this
crate arrives with the cossack motorbike
inside it so we take it apart it's then
got all these wooden pailings we have to
pull off the wheeling padlings to open
it up then there's oil safe rag over
this thing which is tied on a on a
wooden base yeah we take the oil soak
rag off and we stare in all its glory in
a 1942 bmw yeah okay it was exactly the
same as steve mcqueen and yeah great
escape
so the russians for 30 years were making
the same bloody motorbike it had a
bicycle seat yeah okay and this is what
that's how they cope they've just made
the same damn machine every year they
said so that's that's the outcome you
you actually want the best possible
world you're trying to build as fast as
possible you're paying workers as high
wages as you possibly can and that leads
to a world where you don't innovate
you said capitalism on the other hand
pure capitalist economy you're trying to
pay workers as little as possible
you have competitive industries you're
trying to take demand away from your
rivals you have kawasaki versus honda
versus
you know
bmw etc etc the way you get demand away
from your competitors is by innovating
so what you will get is cycles and booms
and slumps but you'll innovate and
change over time
so what you found was this huge gap
between socialist volume production with
no innovation and capitalism with
innovation
so that was the fundamental failing
that janos corner saw saw why did why
does socialism not innovate
because if you go back to
his famous historical incident where
khrushchev in the united nations
bangs takes off his shoe and bangs the
death says we will bury you he literally
meant we're going to bury you in
commodities yeah we're going to produce
more output than you are and he was
wrong
because fundamentally in the long term
to bury somebody
in commodity production you have to
innovate yeah and like there's also
there's another um remarkable soviet
engineer who was given the job of
interpreting marx's ideas of
industrial sectors so he had the
commodity sphere the industry sphere
sector one sector two sector three uh
sector one producing consumer goods
sector two producing capital goods
sector three producing luxury goods for
capitalists and so he had a three sector
model of the economy and he was talking
about the dynamics between them and
what feldman did was reinterpret this as
an engineer would reinterpret it which
was brilliant work
so what he said was uh you you need to
produce the means of production
if you want to grow quickly you focus on
producing the means of production rather
than commodities so you don't make cars
you make car factories
okay you make a few cars but most of the
other goes into expanding how many
factories you have and what he did was
do a mathematical model where you'd
start off with very low levels of
consumer good output but then you would
just go exponential
okay now i took a look at that back when
i was doing my master's degree and the
training in mathematics i took
feldman's equations and then looked at
what was actually driving it was he was
imagining correctly a huge pool of
unemployed labor
if you go back to the earliest stages of
soviet industrialization back in 1917
post the second world post the first
world war
you had all these unemployed workers you
had all these peasants you could take
off the land and put into factories so
you had a huge supply of workers
what you had to do was build the
factories so you're building the
factories but at a certain point you
exhaust the supply of
on lowly employed or unemployed labor
and so rather than having this this
exponential takeoff you hit a ceiling
and then you can only grow as fast as
the population because you're not
innovating
okay so that's what actually hit the
sofa soviet system
and it's why they never buried the
western consumer goods and instead why
eastern consumers looked in envy of the
goods being purchased by their western
people they said if that's exploitation
we want exploitation
so okay there's a lot of interesting
stuff to ask here which is
so marx's vision
for the
socialist
utopia is you have to go through
capitalism
the mensheviks were true to marx's
original idea right so is there
a case to be made that in the long arc
of human history on like human
civilization on earth
that we're going to live out
marx's vision for utopia which is
like will we run into a wall with
capitalism i think we are running into a
war with capitalism in fact i think
we've already gone through the wall and
we haven't yet realized we've smashed
our skulls okay okay
[Laughter]
but on the other side um we're bleeding
and everything like that uh is
does marx have any insights on what the
other side of capitalism would have been
i think that beautiful phrase of ramich
according to his ability to which
according to his needs
describes what we sh we should end up
with
and i think that's actually if i think
about you know you know i'm an elon musk
fan
that's what i think is partially going
to be the nature of society
if we build one that functions on mars
because and i've actually seen the
interview with his the italian who's
involved in designing what the future
colony will look like he was actually
asked this question can there be
enormous inequality in martian
civilization the guy said absolutely not
because the resources again resource
constraint applies
you simply can't give somebody
a underground bunker 100 times the size
of somebody else's 100
underground bunker
there's a the the scarcity of resources
imp imposes a need for uh for equality
overall is that always that's
interesting i mean the scarcity or
resource
wait but i feel like that's the
contradiction i thought
you're thinking you know classical about
scarcity yeah i'm i'm barely thinking at
all
uh so wait i
i thought scarcity the best way to build
on top of scarcity is a capitalist type
of machine no this is this is where
again our vision of what scarcity is is
wrong
because then ricardo said this best
actually better than marx because
ricardo said there are some products
uh whose value is determined entirely by
their scarcity yeah
paintings
rare wines et cetera et cetera
so they are things you cannot reproduce
in a factory so the essence of
capitalism is what you can make in a
factory
and therefore for these unique objects
these rare objects and the picasso
painting
uh you know a beautiful bottle of wine
etc etc then the utility it can't be
reproduced easily so its price will be
determined by subjective valuation you
said what we're talking about in
capitalism is the stuff you can make on
mass okay and that
that that is the true focus of the
capitalist economy and that is not about
scarcity that is about
the only scarcity applies when you don't
have the resources to make them anymore
or you can't use the energy involved
because you'll damage the biosphere with
too much which we've already done okay
but fundamentally the scarcity that
neoclassicals have made us think about
and austrians think about as well
is non-reproducible but the essence of
capitalism is the commodity the back
scratcher the two buck back scratcher
anybody can you know the cheapest chips
to make and that's why you can make a
profit out of them um not not the
elaborate gold thing with diamonds and
rubies that only the king gets so we
think with our vision of scarcity has
been perverted by neoclassicals
analyzing the exception to capitalism
and calling it capitalism
okay fair enough so you know let's put
mars aside because i think there's a lot
of
strange factors that have to do with a
whole other
planet
civilization
that we don't quite understand like how
economics works
with
with different geographic locations one
of which have
new challenges
which is what essentially this is i
don't i don't know if you can apply the
same economy now i'm saying
your question i think
will will be forced into that ultimately
by having to make a compromise with the
ecology
and we've been ruthless about the
ecology of this planet and we're going
to pay the price for it
so
if you have a
planet where you can't be ruthless
okay well yeah okay you have to mine it
as carefully as possible
then
those that that utopian might be imposed
upon you for the needs for survival on
that planet back here
uh
marx's util utopia was still the one
that ignored the ecology
and i think
uh if i have a vision of a utopia in
future it's got bugger all to do about
what humans get out of it
it's what humans respect
they have to respect life
so i don't see that as i see that as a
as a one-eyed utopia utopia for a single
species
as if it can exist on its own which we
should know it can't
you